three Chicago police officers are
charged with an alleged cover-up in
connection with the deadly shooting of a
black teenager David March Joseph Walsh
and Thomas Gaffney were indicted
yesterday on charges that they all
conspired to lie about the actions of
Officer Jason van Dyke
now the dashcam video shows Van Dyke's
shooting and killing 17 year-old laQuan
McDonald in 2014
DeMarco Morgan is here with how that
video led to the charges DeMarco good
morning good morning Gil the charges
filed against the three officers are not
for pulling the trigger but for what
they did after the shooting according to
court documents they are accused of not
only protecting each other but also
their fellow officer who shot McDonald
police dashcam video from October 2014
captures 17 olds laQuan McDonald walking
away from Chicago Police as he carries a
knife in its right hand he's then shot
16 times by Officer Jason van Dyke and
police reports that followed officers
reported that McDonald swung the knife
toward the officers in an aggressive
manner and after he was shot was
attempting to get up while still armed
with the night on Tuesday special
prosecutor Patricia brown Holmes
announced the charges this indictment
alleges that these defendants lied about
what occurred during a police involved
shooting in order to prevent independent
criminal investigators from learning the
truth detective David March and officers
Joseph Walsh and Thomas Gaffney are each
charged with felony counts of conspiracy
official misconduct and obstruction of
justice while they are sworn to serve
and protect as well as uphold the law
they are not above the law and a
statement current Chicago Police
Superintendent Eddie Johnson said the
department is fully cooperated with
prosecutors and is committed to
implementing policies and training to
prevent an incident like this from
happening again following the video's
release in 2015
thousands demonstrated across Chicago
the city's police superintendent was
fired and in January a federal
investigation concluded the department
engaged in the pattern or practice of
excessive force the union for Chicago
police showed us they do not comment on
active investigations Gaffney was
suspended from the force following the
indictment announcement in March and
Walsh no longer worked with the Chicago
Chicago Police Department I should say
their charges carry prison terms of up
to five years Van Dyke has pleaded not
guilty to first-degree murder and is
awaiting trial
Charlie Thank You DeMarco